نشرت واسالوا على من روسيا صورا جديده
قالت انها لشركات لقوات شركات فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه داخل سوليدار
ماكده سيطرتها على كامل المدينه وتظهر صور
انتشار العسكريين الروس وسط البنايات
السكنيه والاحياء وقال التلفزيون الروسينا
عمليه تنشيط اضافيه تجري الان في المدينه
التي باتت فارغه تماما من سكانها بعد ما
تركوها عند بدايه المعارك واشار تلفزيون
الروسي الى امكانيه انطلاق عمليه نزع
الالغام خلال يومين تمهيدا لعوده المدنيين
اليه
وقد اكد يبكيني بريكوجين رئيسه ميليشيا
فاجنر روسيه سيطره مقاتلين على مدينه
سوليدار رغم النفي الاوكراني واشهد
بفعاليه
من الاسباب التي مكنت مقاتليه من السيطره
على مدينه سوليدار شرقيه اوكرانيا تتمثل
بتمرسهم في القتال وانضباتهم الشديد
وقدرهم على تحقيق اهدافهم بصوره مستقله
وامتلاكهم طائراتهم وبدفاعاتهم ومدرعاتهم
الخاصه
واظافر
قياده المجموعه جرى تطويره بما يحقق تنفيذ
المهمات دون تراجع وفق تعبيره